hello and welcome to this video with a
new edition of three minute madness yes
let's get crazy three minutes yes and
I'm getting a very strong opponent first
game yeah I'm playing three minute and
I'm not taking things too seriously
playing as sharp as crazy as possible
yeah against you for it's not so easy to
do I try with the Dutch I'm playing mmm
this is Krishnan shashi kiran probably
mispronouncing this one of the best
players of india maybe he's AI it's
probably not number three there are some
very strong young guys like audubon so
through rahman yeah but he was number
three for a while behind island and um
and Hari Krishna oh it doesn't look good
he's got a night it's got 96 it ah yeah
a three minute madness more like ah well
97 is coming right and okay I have to
give up stuff oh it's not even taking
the exchange that's surprising
I would have thought he takes the
exchange here white might be better but
it's not a win and I really think he
just would have been an exchange up for
nothing yeah he just wants to grind me
down hit an end game that's not nice
it's not it's not so terrible you have
me this position or I don't think this
is so bad his Bishop there's also not
not great that if the g2 bishop yeah he
wants to go G for him let's see Can I
grab a 2 here yes I got that porn isn't
that a very good ending for me it looks
good right over to be five is the thing
and then I can get this rolling Chan
winning apanya that that looks very good
here white person yes good start here
against a shakira is like 26 50 or so
and over the board chest let's get going
you should have visual have just taken
the exchange I think and he is winning I
was surprised now Leningrad star struck
for some reason yeah here he can just
take the exchange there was no reason
not to I think just grab the exchange
even 97 was possible okay give me a game
please start
what something like that Lord your Mincy
okay it's three minute madness so here
we go it did they declined the wind
gambit that's cool can i play ok let's
go e5 the society Nguyen game but you
really should take I think there's no
reason not to grab the porn yeah it's
three minute madness right here we go
what are you doing here going for long
castles maybe hmm maybe finally your
congee three really long but you're not
going to Castle shorty either
okay I'm interesting move now I get it's
not canceling here and then your future
let's see what to do let's look at the
b5 porn very strange position prevent h4
h 3 that seems a little bit awkward my
rook is a absolutely strange piece so
what now yeah maybe night except 7s
scaring him
you yeah my pollen is six but you cannot
so easily take it ok let's open up you
can take the pawn but I'm happy with the
position opening up his King on the 8th
it's not making a good impression yep
let's trade this my rukon g5 is coming
into the game now really has to quincy
for maybe okay i think i'll start with
the capture p5 is hanging but this rook
is also hanging so look T 1
yeah taking a 7 now 27 coming I need to
rope here absolutely so Brooke over to
d7 taking the zoo k 1
rupee a check
maybe you can go Roxy to hear very sharp
move no doesn't feel like it time
warning couldn't be aid again in the mix
just suddenly can perpetual hmm I don't
see a way to win here i have a draw
check who he's trying to play for win I
didn't have that on the radio at all I
thought you would need to draw okay but
he's right i mean he can he can go for
that I a pawn check check check check
check no chat room check what did enough
shower check check yeah hello door and
the win game bit has struck black
forfeits own time okay give me a new
game yeah sometimes is quite nice so
just play some some nonsense openings or
let's say nonsense is a bit strong but
play wacky stuff and see what you what
you manage with it what what wacky stuff
can i play here not much actually
it's that's still reasonably reasonably
okay but yeah for something crazy i
probably should start with another first
move even okay that's not good huh don't
like to play before here but maybe it's
not so bad actually long diagonal is
reasonably is strong Roxy one maybe it
says something directly no I appreciate
you for I don't think this is so bad
actually
rook be one no castles long am I have
this year to have night a six King
disseminate rook c8 coming and looks
nice actually I mean nice it's okay
I really played quickly him
yeah we'll come to see aid with tempo
tempo yeah but it's the right file
anyway yeah I have a six-year if I five
is not looking great hmm
can also go nite b8 actually looks a bit
weird but it's okay night before that
suks e-form it's not good anyway
ninety-seven rupee eight reps the night
I am it's not a trap but close to that
maybe you still should do it on this I
didn't feel that didn't feel so
threatening getting the e porn Jaclyn
I've got some chances here on the on the
beetle porn he seems to be out for e5
here okay let's step out of this out of
the pin
yeah check hey hey I'm taking everything
here just give me give me stuff I'll
take it check okay um what now probably
and five if I'm really up on the clock
lot here there should be five or gauge
for I guess mmmm cannot move the rook
easily time morning let's just prevent
your gauge form with all the madness
let's do something seen something in say
some sane moves
yeah those pawns are strong check check
white for Vince on time yeah good run
here with the other madness i have
playing super aggressive is is paying
off in short time controls three-minute
chess is more like bullet then then
blitz and as aggressive as possible
often good let's see can we keep that
run that's three out of three if i'm not
mistaken i don't get a game here hmm
gain started leukoc a let's see I'm
ready for evil here 'if I've what are
you guys doing I'm playing the wing
gambit and all kinds of weird stuff is
played against it okay fire let's just
fire
that's super weird okay five I wanted I
wanted to play we should be fire but
this is of course completely absolutely
not working okay let's let's just heck
away at this check
Bishop takes d5 mmhmm yeah a queen takes
is just winning stuff back I just wasn't
sure what it what it is how the
evaluation as I mean Chad oh I didn't
see that move at all that's bad I can
take be seven though check let's take
this complete insanity yeah okay um Tiki
64 is still hanging and where is he
going in the first place
come on you know it's remitted chest you
can do anything what is he playing here
27 maybe or something like that yeah
this looks sensible okay take at this
but still no 90 x I mean I'm getting
stuff back and all of a sudden just as
magic yeah I'm a pawn up no I'm two
pawns up which is kind of crazy okay
let's check him again and check check
check check okay what he ever yeah if he
takes it as g3 I'd wins more material I
think he's probably check not liking
this game too much check so let's
develop the night finally I cannot talk
take F for the course of g3 yeah this is
not helping you
mm-hmm see a winning tactic here looks
like there should be one but I don't see
it ok this is yes a winning tactic check
and the seal and there's a sea pawn does
the job yeah it was crazy again but why
why do people play that weird stuff
against the wind gambit a 55 is weird
anyway new game new game
yeah there's the same wing gambit has
struck here I have no idea what this was
I'm not go to analyze those games I just
check went crazy that's probably not
working check at all but well it's a
it's fun at least okay I have requested
a new game but I don't get one seems to
be that they're not that many people
around or gain starting mostly okay
let's play the Blitz kicker what kind of
craziness can we unfold here let's see
um maybe the children that's halfway
crazy now it's not so easy against your
phone to get some something crazy going
ok this is this is crazy enough probably
it's also bad oh he feels provoked okay
understandably g5 really looks like a
complete rubbish okay bishops you form
that means I had some major if I take me
that's it's really the case hmm how to
play that Queen chief phone this may be
coming also 28 there is special f7
that's not good maybe e6 yeah okay I
mean the bad thing is here it's not me
having the initiative at seven and it's
a bit more than initiative probably he
just wins there with good play even
Bishop 6 might be strong pool now now
maybe maybe I can get some square sim
and I checking each X me on l4m and to
be one and so on that's not going to end
well my king is going up to a five here
maybe it's finding something better
Bishop f4 for example is strong i guess
okay i can go back to d8 maybe
I he's got fantastic play here for for
the material but maybe maybe I'm not
losing straightaway
hmm should have six hmm
hi there should be five Wow the good
move
time morning yeah I obsess you to move
him that says you know via
cannot even a sacrifice stuff Bishop f6
is just winning
hmm I cannot no no now that was g5s
reason was probably a bit too crazy but
ok that kid I can't happen gotten away
with some crazy stuff before game
started Oh italic I'm not getting easy
opponents here ok of course the King's
gambit he will probably punish me duly
check
okay at least I'm not material down I
know that's not the proper Kings gambit
attitude but I still like to retain some
kind of sanity okay is that so bad I've
seen worse and the Kings gambit really
did or I really have it's a little bit
better English so let's see and Cairo
this
interesting I it's got a very nice night
they're only five I need to see if I can
get something going with the deeper we
are not easy
you
self in life whether we add move
so what is he doing in knight c6 can
probably sec against that sec the queen
maybe can take on d3 or something no
didn't do it
top position I thought these six here
huh isn't that good these 693 I can take
that power is too strong okay if I time
margin can take only five unfortunately
time tough to play my dears Queen d5
just support the pawn I can still take
it damn
and it's got F for now I have no time no
time 13 seconds no chief or as a move
here check
mmm does it on time you no idea what
this was I mean how the position is to
be assessed probably here I'm losing but
time and time wise didn't matter yeah so
many more time anyway what for fins on
time okay let's do one more game start
don't want to end this session with a
loss I could play the Alvin's which is
this is entirely incorrect ah take away
three I don't you want to refute that
scrap openings guys and I really don't
want to it seems I rather want some
position where they have nothing strange
really strange okay
yeah we transpose to some kind of Queens
gambit accepted with the three your
french exchange we're not much is going
on yeah that's not exactly what you want
when you play the Alvin's I wanted some
some crazy crazy complications instead
he just doesn't do anything play this
this boring setup okay f6 I don't know
Bishop sister like rap deform
threatening 92 threatening 96
I don't have much else than this check
yep not much going on it's just just
very equal okay now he wants to force
the draw I have to make it i guess maybe
I can go 86 it's still a drawing with g7
king of a droopy six
but he has to do that Oh otherwise I
mean
check
time we cannot play that for win
unfortunately really would have liked to
but I have to make a drawing say it's no
way no way forward Zach gain yeah okay a
draw at the end but I think it was a fun
session I hope you enjoyed it yeah good
three minute madness here and there
cannot hurt thanks for watching